hi I'm Erik Bosse and with the next
Avengers movie finally now in our sights
one interesting question leftover from
infinity war was the Hulk look what
happened to this guy what the Sun get so
low for him after thinness Kayode him in
the opening minutes why was he so absent
the rest of the film aside from the
group running shot Wakanda that was only
in the trailer that night the Avengers
for different video and the worse than
that
not too long ago the directors revealed
an interesting insight from Thanos his
fistfight with the Hulk that you might
have overlooked the first 10 times you
watched infinity war and it gives us
some idea of where the character could
go in their upcoming rematch with Thanos
customary spoiler warning okay here's
the issue with the Hulk he obviously
gets beaten down by Thanos in the
opening brawl but Hulk ain't supposed to
lose ever it's kind of his thing the
core of his character DNA like every hit
on the Hulk is supposed to just make him
bigger and angrier he's basically
invincible and could theoretically keep
fighting another invincible into me
forever and ever and ever until their
two old men swatting each other over who
gets the good bench to feed the ducks as
we've seen an age of Ultron and Ragnarok
you could kind of daze the Hulk
temporarily but really he's gonna come
roaring back even more pissed
eventually the classic way to tame the
Hulk it's to go the opposite direction
emotionally appeal to his soft side like
Black Widow doing that weird Suns
getting real low lullaby but an
infinitive or Thanos knocks him out cold
so cold in fact that the hole refuses to
come out again for the rest of the movie
the Russo brothers have explained that
it's not that the Hulk is scared
according to them Hulk is just tired of
playing hero to Bruce Banner
it's a dysfunctional relationship
between the two entities and the Hulk is
no longer interested in letting Bruce
use him to solve his problems and now we
have a better understanding of why
Thanos was able to beat the Hulk and
their fight here's what the Russo
brothers said in an interview
Hulk is obviously very powerful but he's
a little mindless in his fighting style
it's aggressive it's pummeling Thanos is
a Genghis Khan of the universe he's a
very skilled fighter and equally as
strong so when he put those two up
against each other the more skilled
fighter is going to win which is why the
Hulk has a moment where he overpowered
stano's but ultimately Thanos is smarter
sorry Hulk it sounds like you're just
too stupid yeah tired of playing hero is
exactly why I don't do crossword puzzles
guru slows remarks let us do re watch
the fight scene closely indeed in the
first few blows Hulk does appear to
overpower Thanos can actually see the
precise moment they added where the Hulk
squeezes then is hard enough to make the
mad Titan growl and pain but this moment
is also the turning point in the fight
because you can see famous expression
change from being caught off guard to
realizing oh I'm fighting a mindless
pea-brain Oh from here it all goes down
pretty fast but you can definitely see
how Thanos is using his wits to duck
block and deflect Hulk's blows
delivering quick precise hits kind of
like a martial arts expert even at one
point aiming for the hoax ribs as if to
knock his wind out and as the Russo said
they intentionally did not show the
anise is purple power stone lighting up
during this fight said this is raw brute
strength agility and boxing skill Danis
use this hand to hand combat to beat up
the Hulk without using the Infinity
stone with the whole idea being to show
how skills of a Genghis Khan's style
warrior Thanos is they wanted to prove
that this guy is a fierce Conqueror who
has already defeated a number of
civilizations without any magical God
rocks and really we're seeing Thanos at
the end of his warpath beating these
supposedly unbeatable one-on-one is
their dramatic way of showing that if
this mad Titan is fierce enough to knock
out the main untamable brute of the
Marvel films nothing's gonna stop this
guy from getting his stones really that
is beating honk in the opening minutes
should have been a dead giveaway
his victory in the final minutes but if
smarts was really the only thing holds
he and Hulk back against Thanos and
infinity war does that mean a hope with
a slightly higher IQ would have better
chances in the next movie let's look
closely at the hoax evolution throughout
the MCU this journey has been one of
gradual humanization he began as a
belligerent monster but little by little
it has been hinted that Bruce Banner has
more control over the monster and that
this monster has a soul that's my secret
cat I'm always angry so help me out
I need a hand by the time we get to Thor
Ragnarok the Hulk is forming complete
sentences with terrible grammar but
complete and it's leaps and bounds from
the dumb-dumb who was smashing through
the Helicarrier midway through the
Avengers I mean in that scene he might
as well not even have a face he's
basically a boulder and think about it
Hulk being tired of playing hero is a
pretty sophisticated emotion and based
on a little that we've seen for the next
Avengers movie the guy is certainly
becoming less mindless it actually looks
like the movies might be heading toward
the professor Hulk incarnation of the
character from the comics in issue 376
to the Incredible Hulk run titled
personality conflict all of Bruce
banners conflicting personas merged into
one big Hulk with the intelligence of
Bruce Banner you can talk he's just a
smart but he still has the childish
brute body of the Hulk seeing professor
Hulk in the next movie would in a way
not only close out Bruce banners art
from mindless leaf a lien against Thanos
at the start of affinity war it also
close out the arc from the I'm always
angry moment back in the first Avengers
finally revealing the mad scientist and
the Beast Within as one harmonious
entity do you think the Hulk is more
interesting as a monster willing to
bench himself or as an infinitely
uncontrollable rage monster comment down
below with your thoughts and follow new
rock stars on Twitter at new rock stars
and for updates on our videos follow me
on Twitter and Instagram at boss
subscribe the new rock stars for more
Marvel theories and support us on
patreon big thanks to Kelly hopper for
all your support and this has been fun
I'm gonna grab some food because that's
the thing about me
I'm always hungry